За півтора кілометри від селища Луганське
вже окопи
Через постійні обстріли вулицями
тут майже ніхто не ходить
Якби не ці чоловіки, допомогти бабусі,
яка втратила свідомість просто посеред дороги
було б нікому
Навіть у амбулаторії, що навпроти, - порожньо
Додому вас? Чи може почекаємо лікаря?
Ні, давайте додому
Бабусі викликають лікаря, наполягають,
щоб вона записала номери телефонів
та беруть з неї обіцянку
завжди носити пігулки з собою
Це офіцери цивільно-військового співробітництва
спеціального підрозділу збройних сил України, створеного за стандартами НАТО
На Донбасі їх називають "Сіміками",
відповідно до англійської абревіатури
Вони посередники між армією та населенням
Офіцери не виконують бойових операцій
а допомагають населенню долати
наслідки російської агресії
Приміром, відновлювати зруйноване "Градами"
як на День Святого Миколаяу Ново-Луганському
Ми коли приїхали, там канєшно
був "філіал ада на землі"
Все горіло. Були пробиті газогони.
Горіли будинки, всьо було в диму, люди в істериці
Після цього все це треба було відновлювати,
повертати до нормального життя
Усі "Сіміки" мають бойовий досвід
та пройшли навчання
як поводитися із мирнимнаселенням,
яке втомилося від війни
Часто офіцери самі хапаються за інструменти
і починають ремонтувати будинки
Вони тут іноді і поліція,і МНС, і швидка допомога
Також саме вони, з міркувань безпеки
доставляють гуманітарний вантаж
для жителів прифронтових селищ
На Донбас зі усієї країни надсилають одяг,
речі першої необхідності
для найбільш беззахисних перед війною – пенсіонерів та дітей
І це дитячий одяг.
У насдуже багато малозабезпечених
Ісімей, які неспроможні самі купити.
Все зараз дорого
З вікон цієї школи біля Світлодарська
дітям часто доводиться бачити вибухи
Навчити їх вберегти життя -
це теж завдання "Сіміків"
Зараз в цьому районі, де ви проживаєте
ні в якому разі не можна ходити де? По посадках
Вони можуть бути заміновані
Налагодити діалог з населенням
і покращити ставлення до української армії
це головні цілі підрозділу
цивільно-військового співробітництва
Адже на початку війни в прифронтових районах
не дуже раділи українській армії
І зараз не усі кажуть "дякую",
говорить Максим Косенко
На мій погляд, більше всього змінюється ставлення… Це люди похилого віку і діти
Люди середнього віку, мабуть, мають свою сталу життєву позицію. Там тенденція змін низька
Рано чи пізно ці настрої на Донбасі зміняться, впевнений 40-річний майор Збройних сил
А свою "цивільну місію" військові
вважатимуть виконаною лише тоді
коли нормальне мирне життя
буде відновлене аж до російського кордону